hello guys and girls raj here back with
another video
so this is beginning of the march all
the companies are hiring on full force
for the cloud jobs
and in the cloud interview devops is a
super
important topic so this week's video
we are going to go over some of the
devops interview questions
from moderate to advanced more suitable
for the architect level or lead
devops engineer level so the questions
we are going to cover today
are what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment
explain a devops pipeline that you have
implemented
and we are going to do that by
explaining a kubernetes
pipeline then tell me about a
challenge you faced with devops
how do you implement unit testing in
devops
how do you implement security in your
pipeline and is infrastructure as
code necessary for devops pipeline
and finally how will you implement
changes
in multiple aws accounts as always
i have given the timestamps for your
viewing convenience
all right let's get started so question
one
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment
so devops has these four main phases
source build test and prod sources
when you check in your source code a
build is
when you compile your code unit test run
unit test
and you create the artifact such as like
a jar file
or zip file that is ready to be
implemented
then you test you do integration testing
with other systems
load testing ui testing penetration
testing etc
and then you deploy the artifact to the
production
so the source and the build phase
is termed as continuous integration
where the code is compiled
unit testing is done and the artifact is
created
and that is ready to be deployed
continuous delivery
is the process of deploying that
artifact to the prod
with a manual intervention so you guys
and girls see this
a checkpoint sign that means that once
all the unit testing
and the integration testing has been
done and before it gets deployed to the
production
a human comes and checks if everything
is okay
if everything is fine he or she clicks a
button
and the package gets deployed into
production
continuous deployment as you can see
there is no
checkpoint so continuous deployment is
the process
of deploying the artifact
without any human intervention if all
the automated testing
is passed then it gets automatically
deployed
but if the automatic testing fails then
it stops sends a notification
then some human comes and take a look
all right next
explain a devops pipeline that you have
implemented
so when they ask that generally if you
can give
a kubernetes example or a serverless
example that's
impressive because kubernetes is pretty
hot right now
so in this video i'm gonna go over a
kubernetes pipeline
so the big picture for kubernetes
pipeline is
the developer checks the code into a
code repository
and then the code is dockerized and
a container image is created from that
code
and then this docker container
and this container image is stored into
a container image
repository and then it is deployed
into a kubernetes cluster
the process till the container image is
stored into a repository is the build
process
and then the next part is the deployment
so basically continuous integration
and then either continuous delivery or
continuous deployment
so if we want to take it one step
further the code repo
could be github and to dockerize
your application you need some tool
to run some commands right and then
the container image can be stored in a
container image repository
and in the deployment phase again
you need some tools to run commands to
deploy
those images into the kubernetes cluster
and those commands could be easy using
help
helm commands or cube ctrl commands
so if we take these concepts and go one
step
further this is the actual pipeline
a code gets checked into let's say git
and
some of the tools where you can run the
dockerize commands
could be gitlab or code build or jenkins
and then it could be stored in let's say
ecr or elastic container registry
or tried tested docker hub
again the deployment could be done via
jenkins
code deploy or gitlab so basically any
devops tool
that can run helm or cube ctl commands
and that could be deployed
in a eks or elastic kubernetes cluster
in aws or it could be any cloud really
the flow should remain
the flow will remain the same so on this
i actually have a separate video where i
show
how do you test your code in local
machine then you dockerize it create a
container image
in your local machine test that
container in your local machine
and then how you migrate that to the
cloud then you
expose it to the outside world scale it
etc
so basically end to end i'll give the
link up top as well
check it out if you are interested
moving forward tell me about a challenge
you
faced in devops so what the interviewer
is trying to see is
not just the challenge the interviewer
is looking
how you solved it so one of the
challenge i faced
was we were running pipeline
using jenkins and jenkins generally in
aws
or any cloud you have to run in a vm
right so there is a primary node
and then depending on the workload the
other secondary nodes get
spun up so if lot of teams
are deploying changes or checking in
code
at the same time sometimes it's very
slow to scale and sometimes it cannot
keep
up because the primary node has a fixed
size
and to upgrade it to a bigger size
requires some manual intervention
or it takes some time even if you want
to do it automated way
so there is a scaling challenge with
that we also faced idle cost
because jenkins runs in an ec2 server
even if there is no deployment going on
you still have to pay for that primary
ec2 node
it has a steep learning curve and also
it's hard to troubleshoot because
there are so many jenkins plug-in if the
team just adopted a new plug-in
they have to get used to how the plug-in
does error reporting and all that stuff
so how did i solved it so i used code
pipeline for newer projects
uh code pipeline scales automatically
it doesn't use any ec2 or any server it
is serverless
so it is pay as you go and i could use
all my existing aws learning such as
checking metrics in cloudwatch
uh cloudtrail etc uh to use quad
pipeline
and also it integrates really well with
other aws services
if i want to call the cloud formation if
i want to
invoke a lambda or some other aws
services
it supports all that out of the box if
you don't want to
mention code pipeline because it's cloud
specific you can also mention gitlab
runner
so gitlab runner also solves some of the
challenges that jenkin has
actually that recent gitlab runner can
run on a forget
so you don't have to pay for uh the ec2
and it scales uh pretty well so moving
on
how do you implement unit testing in
devops
so for this you use a unit testing
framework
so how you do it is you create a code
in that code this is just for testing
you execute your code that you are
trying to implement so if you have
created a jar file
to be implemented but it hasn't been
implemented yet
you execute your code with predefined
input
and you know what output you
should get for those predefined input
and once you get the output
you match that actual response with the
expected
response and and if it doesn't match
you can also control the percentage of
error let's say you call your code 10
times
and if 80 percent of test case passes
then it's good
so if 88 test case pass then you could
mark it as
complete but depending on that if it is
less than 8
then you can error it out and
where do you implement this code so one
way
uh i have done it is in the pipeline
implement a lambda
and this lambda using this unit testing
framework
calls your actual code match
compare all that stuff and either error
out or pass
so if you want to see this in action i
also have a separate video
where i show with actual demo how i
implemented this in the pipeline
so i'm going to give the link up top
feel free to check it out as well
moving on very important topic how do
you implement
security in your devops
pipeline so this goes into the dev set
up statory so
devops plus security so security of the
devops
life cycle so the first thing you have
to implement
is authorization as in the person
who is who is submitting the pipeline
does he or she have have the authority
to
implement the application so generally
how we implement it is when you submit
a check in a code and a devops job gets
submitted we know who submitted or
checked in the code
and we know what application
that code is being deployed to so
generally we have a ldap group
and that user should be part
of that ldap group for that application
that's how we check if the user has
permission or not
you can also implement it using iam user
groups
different ways but if the user is in the
group
the pipeline goes fine if the user who
submitted
this code or the devops pipeline
is not in that ldap group or the iam
user group
then it is rejected and the pipeline
fails
another part of implementing a security
in the devops is
you have to scan your code for
vulnerabilities
such as you should scan cloud formation
for poor security
uh so like if you are creating a
security group in the cloud formation
with everything very open anyone can
come and
access your application it should check
that
you can scan code for vulnerable
libraries sql injection etc
like if you're using some library in
your code which is
not secure check against the osap top 10
vulnerabilities
etc you also scan the repository for
docker container
you should scan the image and see if the
image is secure
and you can also scan the running code
and
container so when the code is running or
the container is running in the
production you should also scan that
it will be impressive if you mention the
tool names
so for example the scan coding for
vulnerabilities
you can scan cloudformation using cfn
nag
it's open source plugin there are also
many tools that you can
use you can google it one of them is
like parliament and there are many
others
scanning code for vulnerable libraries
you can use
fortify for this can rip scan repository
if you are using ecr ecr gives you this
feature
you can also use tools like sysdig falco
etc to scan your container repository
scan running code container you can use
a twist lock
for container for scanning scan running
code you could use a black dock
and you could google it there are many
other tools
finally uh this is again you can impress
the interviewer
so the devsecops is general security
best practice
you you said all that then mention that
hey
if your application needs even more
security compliance
such as fedramp high hippa sock etc
say that you can appropriately pick
golf cloud instead of commercial cloud
right and you can pick and choose
different services
that is compatible with the security
compliance requirement
so i'm going to give a link in the
description you can check it out for aws
what services are what compliant like
what aws
devops services or fedramp hi hipa etc
so you can give couple of this example
if you are interviewing in a company
with a very high security requirement
also it's a good idea to explain with
one actual example
like if you are interviewing for like a
kubernetes architect or something
you don't have to go through like
regular scanning code you can explain
with one example
moving on is infrastructure as
code necessary for devops pipelines
so this is a trick question right so
infrastructure as code example is aws
cloud formation right
so you can run a cloud formation from a
devops tool
or yourself and it spins up aws
infrastructure
there are other ways to spin up
infrastructure as well
such as you can run aws cli commands
right so basically in your devops
pipeline you can have
some plugin or a compute
or a tool which can run a wscli command
to go spin up aws resources
so infrastructures code is not
absolutely necessary
but it makes your life much easier so
this is the part the interviewer is
trying to
listen from you right trying to see if
you answer this
so infrastructure as code makes it
faster
why because it's easier to change
and version control infrastructures code
template
than commands right because you can
check in the
template in a git and you can revision
it etc
and you can run tools on it than just
aws cli commands
also generally with this infrastructure
and
infrastructure as code tools such as
let's say cloud formation
or cdk aws gives you
controls and monitoring where you can go
and track changes to the infrastructure
like before you deploy a cloud formation
you can run a change set and see
what changes are being done right before
you run the template
so there are a lot of out-of-the-box
features that you get with
infrastructure's code
with just running the awscli commands
you do not get all that
also all devops tools support
infrastructure as code
any tool you name such as code pipeline
jenkins gitlab flux spinnaker etc
they all support infrastructure as code
for running cli you need to code the
iwscli commands in plugin or maybe
like in lambda or something and put it
in your pipeline so
there is additional management overhead
and headache
for running cli commands in devops
pipeline
also try to understand why
is the interviewer asking that is the
interviewer
thinking that if they use cloud
formation
for example they might get locked into
one cloud
so mention that hey you can all use
tools like terraform which is
infrastructures code
which can help you deploy infrastructure
in any cloud so you don't get locked in
into a particular cloud
and you can use this terraform from any
devops tools along with all these
advantages
that i just went through all right
moving on
how will you implement changes in
multiple aws accounts
so again this is a really realistic
questions
that if you haven't worked in actual
devops project you will never face this
because
if you are just learning devops you are
doing everything in one account
but in reality enterprises have multiple
production or test accounts and you
cannot just
go and implement in each account
separately it is
impossible so how do you do this
using devops pipeline so how you do this
is using a hub and spoke model so it
looks like a bicycle
tire right with hub as the central
account
and then the spokes are in different
child accounts
the central account is called a primary
or master or shared services account
this master account assumes roles
in all these child accounts and then
submits cloud formation stacks so
all the devops tools and administration
needs to be done
only in this master account so you
submit
let's say cloudformation stack once in
this master account using devops
pipeline and this master account
can assume role in the accounts that you
wanted to go and do it
and just submit cloud formation stacks
into multiple
accounts so you don't have to define the
same
devops pipeline in all these separate
accounts and you don't have to go and
submit
each separately so this is a this is a
trick question this
you know for those of you who are
working in actual enterprise projects in
devops
you know that's how you implement this
all right so that's all the questions
and answers
also coming up i am preparing myself
for kubernetes certifications uh so i
plan to do a lot of videos and hands-on
and practice tests
for these kubernetes certifications so
i'm gonna do that all in youtube
uh so please like and subscribe uh if
you want to be part of that
also if you like this video smash that
like button
click subscribe let me know in the
comment section if there are any other
devops interview questions that you want
me to cover
all the likes and subscribe really help
this channel grow
we are almost at 10 000 subscribers
can't wait till we cross that milestone
all right with that guys and girls i end
this video i'll see you guys and girls
in the next video
bye